it's Fan Appreciation Month it's screen
junkies and to reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that
you voted for here's your number three
choice based on a sneaker commercial
comes a film that got the rights to
Michael Jordan and the Looney Tunes then
said screw it that's all the work we're
gonna put into this one it's money time
space jam experience the Citizen Kane of
live-action/animated hybrid basketball
movies full of bright colors cartoon
violins someone's killing someone and
second-tier mid-90s NBA stars that blew
the tiny mind of every kid who saw it
and permanently blinded them to its many
many flaws flip millennials I know
you're just getting old enough to feel
nostalgia for the first time but trust
me this one sucks Journey to the Center
of the Earth where all the Looney Tunes
live apparently for a story about aliens
stealing the talent of basketball
players to win a game against Bugs Bunny
to rescue a failing amusement park ah
that's so lazily told no one even cares
that Michael Jordan got kidnapped I
think Michaels all right before I hate
to leave him like this oh I'm sure he's
fine cartoons are real you know that
your friends are cartoon characters yeah
so or that Bill Murray can travel
between dimensions how did you get here
anyway
producers a friend of mine just her team
should come and drop me off I mean I'm
not mad that he's in this just try even
a little bit next time the movie doesn't
even take place in space it's called
Space Jam return to Michael Jordan's
weird baseball era that conspiracy
theorists think was a secret suspension
for gambling if we win to give them big
players the talent back if you win you
give me hmm then cringe as your
childhood hero shows off the limitations
of his non basketball skills like
bagging your cartoon you're not real
Kochi let's just go out have fun yeah
being a good teammate somebody steal the
ball gets me being a good friend
miss Pacers you guys think wearing
appropriate size khakis and being a role
model this goes against everything they
taught me in health class you want to
win or not
yikes unless you're dunking on somebody
don't be like my kids cling to your flea
innocence with all your favorite Looney
Tunes or at least these bootleg
sound-alikes now the noblank is dead
what's up doc and Rev your engine's for
that a view of Lola bunny Oh whoo Kate
boys a weird rabbit fetish long before
Judy Hopps as you laugh along with all
their classic cartoon hijinks and
conveniently forget that most of this
movie's runtime is dedicated to Newman
trying not to get fired at one of the
worst refereed games of basketball since
the ref and Air Bud let a dog on the
court
he's right ain't no rules to the dog
can't play basketball with dozens of
flagrant fouls shady scorekeeping and a
blatant disregard for solid fundamentals
but if you don't find a fifth player
your team will forfeit the game oh now
you care about the rules where were you
and the two players in the toon squad
shut up Monstar in the face so enjoy a
90-minute long commercial get your hands
on lace up your Nikes grab your Wheaties
and your Gatorade will pick up a Big Mac
on the way to the ballpark that in
retrospect only exists to sell Looney
Tunes toys and Air Jordans cool shoes
but sadly is still the best movie
starring an NBA player you realize Who I
am
I'm your JD ah Space Jam 2 with LeBron
it is starring a soundtrack that totally
makes up for the mediocre movie SEALs
version of fly like an eagle salt and
pepper are Kelly's I believe I can fly a
duet between Chris Rock and Barry White
more arc la and that quad city djs on
that's all come on and slam and welcome
to the jam you know so good NBA Jam
tounament edition you know what else is
better than the movie the original
website that Warner Brothers hasn't
changed since 1996 be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers
thanks to superfans Austin B Connor M
and Alicia G for voting for this trailer
and making Fan Appreciation Month that
much cooler if you want more Fan
Appreciation Month click the Box in the
lab to watch your fifth and fourth
choice honest trailers or if you're
feeling a bit odd click the Box on the
right for a delightfully weird interview
with Vin Diesel from xxx return of
xander
age I believe I can fly I believe I can
touch the sky the entire B movie script
call Kenny Loggins cuz you're in the
danger zone
Koichi slooshy you're not my brother
you're just a pet who grew legs he's got
you in Shrek made it's all over now